the jurogan experience what was it like
fighting again
after all those years
hey listen i did just told this
dmt stuff
and i guess i lost that weight and i
said i don't know what happened i just
don't know what happened i didn't say
i'm gonna do this well it's funny
because you talked to me on the podcast
before the first time you came on and
you said i can't even work out because
if i work out my ego will get excited
but i did this toad and then i said you
gotta do this and you have to do it i
told told you you have to the dmt told
you time to fight
i lost the weight
and it started off with me at first
fighting bob sapp at first that's right
the k1 event i was there for that i was
there live
in the ring with them you said marcus
the queensberry rules but listen
the fight i fought with roy jones was
supposed to be with bob sapp oh really
oh no kidding hell yeah i wouldn't have
to chase this guy all around
so the next thing you know got and um
roy jones got involved and other
fighters holyfield got involved and
then they turned into a fiasco and then
the young guy
jake paul yeah he got involved then and
that's how he that's how the birth of
jake paul began
when you get challenged by someone who's
uh
a guy like a jake paul does that piss
you off is it part part of it that just
like
my um
no it doesn't i don't know i think it's
awesome
you think it's cool
that's awesome that's awesome but you
handle it that way
because like
in a way i mean
it's
it's kind of insulting it's brave it's
bold of him but it's also it's like
jesus christ there's levels to this
world
let me let me know what i found out um
this gentleman um he was a mayor in this
town in the midwest right you know
talked to me for and he was one of those
stern guys he always got the bills paid
always got your lights on they always
got everything right and perfect but he
didn't have a good personality and he
almost lost to a guy that didn't do
anything he didn't make anything she
[ __ ] on people's taxi method but he hung
out with the people he smoked cigarettes
with him he drank with him he ate with
him and going to he hang on the porch
with him yeah and that's when you learn
you can't take yourself too
serious right i mean the world will turn
on you if you take yourself two states
who the hell am i to take myself too
serious made all this money got this
reputation and now i'm looking at
people's
screw facing them down right have a
great life how am i gonna be mad at
stuff i really really think about it
when my ego is not involved how could i
really be mad at somebody that's
beautiful that's a beautiful attitude
and you're so right because there's so
many people that are so concentrating on
they're concentrating so much on
succeeding and doing great things was me
i just wanted to win so bad
i wanted to be somebody so bad it wasn't
even funny yeah and you forget what life
is about life is about thank you life is
enjoying moments life is a balance in
life your legacy is not what you
accomplish is what your children say
about you
at the end of the day
they know who you are they know what
you're hiding that you don't know what
else to see i'm sure you are a fan of
miyamoto musashi i'm sure tell me about
the japanese warrior book of five rings
yes it was all about balance that was
this whole thing is it like an uh a a
samurai has to be an artist you have to
be able to do calligraphy you have to be
able to paint you have to be able to
write poetry
he felt like if you had any imbalance
like if you were like too aggressive or
too peaceful like any imbalance was
dangerous he's like you had to be like
perfectly centered so you had to be a
person who understood all things yeah
that's true to work everything that's
true but um
everybody can um express themselves
being centered yeah people have to be
totally insane to express themselves
they're totally introverted to express
themselves and i don't know why it's
like that i think he's talking about it
from a point of fighting with swords
self-control yeah most fighters that
our main problem is self-control that's
what i mean for sure yourself yes yeah
and it gets worse as you get more
successful and more destructive and more
you know conqueror you're the [ __ ]
guy in sports illustrated you're the
[ __ ] man i mean it's just
when you're a guy who's in a position
like you were in when you were 20 years
old like i've had this conversation with
many people like do you understand the
kind of self-control it would take to be
the baddest man on the planet and you're
only 20.
yeah it takes a lot of thoughts which is
crazy
it's a crazy position to be in
so like imbalance at that point your
life was almost impossible
like to be like
it was strict fighting no girl she's
strict it's too much this is this it was
this
if i that was bad oh god [ __ ] i can't
make that happen i gotta spawn do better
tomorrow
that was bad okay i gotta move my head i
got hit today i got a black guy oh god
but customer's gonna be mad at me if you
see me do this if you see me get hit and
it was just everything was on being
perfect
do you think that that's what it takes
to make someone who is as good as you as
young as you you have to be completely
obsessed
me mike
i'm an obsessed mentality type of person
and at that point in time i mean
i mean to achieve what you achieved so
quickly too you know like you met cos
when you were like what 13 12 12. so
from 12 to 20. i mean that's wild that's
a wild 12-19 he died when i was 19 but
the fact is um
that i
i um
i put so much of myself into boxing my
emotions and everything
that was magnificent that was great but
then when i came to life it was
disastrous right imagine being imagine
being the guy that's just so boom always
in the person say hey hey hey baby i
love you hey what's up hey and i'm just
that manic type of person with
everything yeah yeah
i love you but he's going to stop
hey what i do hey stop no problem sorry
no no
oh man